I think that the biggest change in the  world today is how computing is no  longer a specialized tool for a limited  view we have a new world where both  storage communications transistors  sensors have eventually become free or  they soon will be and the various  applications that these will be used in  are limitless and I look forward to the  time where we see combinations of this  use in non-traditional areas and I have  already seen but look forward to even  more impact in things like politics how  people vote genetics medicine how people  travel communicate and so I think what  we're going to see is a huge explosion  of various uses of computing that we've  never thought of and that the last few  years has really just been the start